i'm gin ryu getting ready for his 16th
start of the season last time out he
picked up his seventh win of the season
and got a very good era at 3
41. j.p crawford leads things off as
usual next pitch on the way swinging a
fly ball
into the right field corner that's going
to be a fair ball in toward the corner
jp the turn at first heading for second
up with the ball is hernandez the throw
to second cutoff by the second baseman
marcus simeon
and jp crawford leads off the ball game
with a ringing double into the right
field corner
holy smokes he's been something
designated hitter mitch haniger
laced into right field for a base hit
crawford will be held at third
now the mariners have runners down the
corners right away
table set for kyle seeger
nearing the line scooped up and a throw
onto first base
guerrero can't hold on crawford scores
haniger is able to take third well for
kyle it's right off the end of the bat
swinging bunt
a pretty good throw but guerrero at
first doesn't make the catch i think
they'll give kyle an infield hit an rbi
and then hannigan moving to third on the
error
runners on it first and third nobody out
and here's ty france here's the one two
to france
and the center and gretchek is able to
keep his feet making the catch hanniger
is coming home
and he slides in safe mariners hang a
crooked number against ryu and the blue
jays right away in the top of the first
they're in front two nothing as you say
kikuchi is up on the mound for the
mariners today
has allowed just two total runs in his
previous three starts combined
marcus
there's a draft this one is gone
off the top of the fence and out of the
ballpark a lead off home run for marcus
simeon
blue jays don't get discouraged when
they're
trailing early i'll tell you because
they can hit
and they can hit for power they're never
out of games
this is shed long junior the the fielder
shed long is caught looking at strike
three one out that is a good sign if
he's hitting that outside
corner against lefties here's jake
fraley hitch out of the way
swung on it belted deep to right field
going and going and goodbye
baseball into the terrace and
straightaway right
jake fraley with his sixth home run of
the season
holy smokes the mariners have now
homered in 10 consecutive ball games
it's now the mariners three and the blue
jays won
that is impressive 2-2 pitch
and just drove it way out to right field
rbi number 19 3-1 seattle
oh there's a good change-up right in the
great spot tough play down the right
side ronnie guerrero makes a heck of a
play that's a tough play for a first
baseman running away from the infield
athleticism of vladimir guerrero on
display right there
over the shoulder like a wide receiver
to bring up shed long junior
this is lashed out towards right field
shed long junior incoming take cover
he goes deep for the third time it's a
two-run
shot and the mariners are taking it to
ryu in buffalo
the last couple of innings scoring some
runs with two outs
here's beau buchet 2-2 pitch a big one
and
fastball going on and miss struck him
out good work by kikuchi
have some 98 where you can get out of
the inning if you can retire
kyle seeger wing in a line drive at
first caught by guerrero and that
will retire the side kyle seeger hit a
screaming mimi but right at vladimir
guerrero junior patrick murphy will come
in murph
there's a curveball hit hard right to
the short stop well one hopper bushed
rights himself
and throws the first one down boy bose
interclock that time was
really good against france he didn't
hurry
himself took his time kicks that ball
sets himself gets his feet underneath
him and throws a strike
done he went after that one the high
fastball at 98 more strikes out one out
for the blue jays and that'll bring out
santiago espinol
and the 2-2 on the way swaying animes by
espional for strike three
so another strikeout for you say kikuchi
his second
and two outs for the blue jays here in
the bottom of the fifth inning here's
rhys maguire the kid from kentwood high
school the 1-2 to mcguire swing and a
miss and a breaking ball down and away
for strike three
back-to-back strikeouts for you say
kikuchi with three on the afternoon
he's been absolutely outstanding simeon
leading off blue jay's sixth inning
one two pitch swinging a miss and a
cutter beautiful
three consecutive strikeouts now for yk
it's in the chase 89 out of the strike
zone that swung on hit
to right field base hit bauer's tracking
it down going towards the line gets it
back in
it's cut off man so just the fourth hit
today by these explosive blue jays
high leg kick that swing is so
level that's how you hit line drives
here's
guerrero with one out and one on two
twos swung on
bounce to the shortstop jp to dylan
moore for the first
double play right on time and that'll do
it
for the jays in the six first half bat
right now with the runner in scoring
position
at the knees paint at 96. springer
head on back working the outside corner
trying to go to the inside corner
or in the middle of the plate but right
at the bottom at the knees 96 miles an
hour
hernett is at second after the double
grichik now batting
swaying and a miss struck him out back
door breaking ball
back to back strikeout six for the
afternoon
two down and the seventh off the outside
corner and gets into chase
going on hit to the left side jp
crawford step
throw got him inning over seven
complete wonderfully done by you say
kikuchi
here's beshette one on two away
low gets jammed and it's what into the
outfit that's gonna drop for a base hit
simeon's gonna
come in to score i'll tell you what
if you're trying to teach a team how to
hit you should look at this boujee's
team because they use the whole field
that base hit hurt because bo got jammed
but he's rewarded with an rbi single
sea waltz coming in the slider monster
will be facing off against vlad guerrero
jr
he tries to check he goes around and
paul
seawall strikes out vlad guerrero jr
two on for the mariners with nobody out
here in the top of the ninth
this is lying in the right field for a
base hit crawford
is coming around third jp steam at home
he scores standing kyle seeger drives in
the sixth run of the game for the
mariners
they play a little add-on at six to two
in the ninth inning one away one on one
in and the banner will be right fielder
jake bowers
as this finds right field and will bring
home another run
mitch haniger trots down the line
mariners have put
seven across today in buffalo two outs
two on he faces kevin biggio
cuts right through 93 top shelf
seawall strikes out the side and nails
down a
7-2 mariners win as they wrap up this
road trip
in fine form